[Music]
let's go to lori in oh claire wisconsin
what's up lori
hey hey dr john i feel like we're old
friends i've never missed a show and
this week i listened to your 300th
episode so congratulations on that i
thank you for that i appreciate that i i
i am first in line to think we were not
going to make it that far
having fun thank you for thank you for
riding in our gang man i'm really
grateful yeah so what's up
so today i just have a question about
guild
so last september my uncle died
unexpectedly and i was appointed the
executor of the estate
he lived in new orleans i live in
wisconsin and my brother at the time
lived in alaska
and i was starting a new job at the end
of september and time wasn't really
something we had much of
so my brother flew from alaska to st
louis and i flew to st louis to his
brother-in-law's house and then we drove
to
new orleans where i rented a u-haul
just to take back you know a few things
from my uncle's house so
when we got there
you know we just
tore through the place like a tornado
and what we were basically looking for
were you know important documents you
know the deed to the house were there
any tax forms his wallet is checkbook
bills you know any financial documents
and
i just feel very guilty that we went
into this man's house just went through
everything you know obviously we
couldn't keep much
and i just feel really bad that we seem
to just
throw this man's life away
and this was right after hurricane ida
had came through so fema was still
picking up all these you know
garbage at the end of the curb but
basically we ended up throwing out
most of this man's possessions we did
work with the local church agency where
we donated a bunch of stuff
but you know he was a police officer
most of his life and he had you know
certificates and awards and plaques and
badges
and you know we just we couldn't keep
all that and we threw it all away
so fast forward to this year where i am
now and my dad is on hospice
he's probably not going to see
september and i'm going to be in the
same boat
obviously well my brother and i will
have more time he does live back home
now
but this is the home that i grew up in
as a child and how do i
just go through that home and just get
rid of everything yeah
number one i'm so sorry
thank you
uh you must be somebody special for both
of these men these important men in your
life to appoint you as the person to
see through things
right pretty cool and come on man could
they have picked somebody else right
it's both in
oh
um
so guilt is guilt is good let's don't
try to avoid guilt okay i don't think
guilt is the challenge here
challenge here is um do you have a good
relationship with your uncle do you like
him
oh yes he was my best friend and you
know it just
was so unexpected that was quite a shock
yeah
um i'm thinking of my uncles
and i've got several of them and they
all have very particular
ways they dress
and i got some more like central uncles
and some straightforward uncles i got
one uncle that smells a little bit like
leather
cowboy
got an uncle that's a tech guy kind of
smells like an iphone i guess i don't
know what this smells like google i
guess
um
here's what i'm getting at
it was about a year ago i was cleaning
out some things in my closet and i found
a jacket like a like a sports coat
of that my granddad used to wear my
granddad died
the greatest man i've ever known
greatest man i've ever met
and i kept that jacket it didn't fit i
always had dreams of it fitting and then
getting it fixed and tailored and it has
i've carried it around for a long long
time and he actually gave it to me
before he died so i've been carrying it
for years
and i was getting rid of clothes and i
put it back on the rack and then i took
it off and here's the words i said to
myself my granddad is not in this jacket
and i put my hand on my chest and i said
my granddad's right here
and your uncle's not in those
certificates and those badges and he
would have told you throw all that crap
away
you know what i mean
and yet
there's something that tells us no uncle
uncle whoever is in that stuff and he's
not he's with you
and then with your dad very very similar
can your dad still hear you and
understand you
oh yeah yep
have you written him the letter and read
it to him yet
no you need to do that asap
okay
what he means to you
what he um
what you're gonna take from what he gave
you
and how you're gonna communicate that on
um
how his life meant something
and then what you will have is one of
the most precious moments a person can
have on planet earth which is the moment
to consciously and directly and with
love say goodbye
with purpose and meaning and dignity
and
then you're gonna have to tell yourself
he's not in that stuff
i would also challenge you to tell your
place where you work if it at all
possible dude i need a week off because
my dad died
and god help him if they don't give you
a week off good grief
or two weeks for crying out loud
right
i've known people that
turn objects into people
and that's a life of misery
[Music]
okay yep and all the things i'm saying
are not easy
none of this is easy
are there a couple of sentimental things
about the
you remember from your dad
oh yeah he was into model trains so you
know he's got all this
model train sets and stuff and my
brother nor i are interested in that
right um don't throw those out there's
some wacky dudes who want to buy some
trains man you want to sell those i paid
for your retirement but
but maybe grab one that you love that
you remember
yeah i had a ceramic i don't know why i
had a ceramic
my wife my grandmother collected ceramic
birds and every time i walked in the
house she reminded me you're not allowed
to touch those
this is going to shock you lori but i
was a bit destructive as a child i was
just chaotic and like a ball of energy
luckily luckily i've grown up and i've
become uh very still and on time and
uh
right whatever
um
and when she died right before she died
she said like anything you need want
from here
and i was like i need that ceramic blue
jay in the ceramic cardinal
and that's what i got i got those two
things
and she's not in those things she's in
my heart she's um she's in
my raising of my kids but i keep those
two things and whenever i see a cardinal
out when i'm hunting out in the woods or
something i see a cardinal and i just
smile
right it's so when my dad passes away
there's two or three things i've already
told my brother and sister i i get these
three things
and
anything else then we whatever just give
it away but there's a couple things that
mean a lot to me that just remind me of
my old man right he's not in them but
they remind me so maybe think of a
couple of things and say these are gonna
be mine a pocket knife and a badge and a
train right something like that and then
everything else man he's just not in
that stuff
that's true yes
but i sure think this is way more
related to the loss
the sudden loss and the pending loss
than it is about the guilt over the
homes i think guilt is probably
misplaced grief
yeah i think you're right now that
you've explained it that way
your life will be really rich if you
write that letter and read it to him
yeah you're absolutely right i need to
get working on that
today
today yes
lori okay
um
after he passes
yes
um
you don't have to but i welcome
if you uh want to send me a draft of the
letter i'll read it over the air so
people can know how great your dad was
that would be wonderful cool to honor
him like that and you could tell him
there's this podcast that like 13 people
listen to dad
we're gonna we're gonna blow you up on
it
they're gonna be famous dad you're gonna
be famous
and he's gonna say i i heard that
podcast i probably don't want to be on
that one
can you get me on joe rogan's podcast
it's way bigger
[Laughter]
they'll be fantastic hey can i tell you
this
sure
man
i ca i can't tell you
as the dad of a six-year-old little girl
i hope my baby girl loves me in my final
days as much as you love your old man
she will he's a lucky
i'm kind of a mess
but your dad man
god almighty what a lucky lucky man
what a lucky man to have lori is as his
eldest that's his daughter
incredible
thank you so much for calling uh let us
know how that um reading him that letter
goes
and if you any way possible read it in
person it's worth the plane ticket
uh maybe if you don't have the money
it's worth the plane ticket go down
there and make sure you see him in
person
then think of a couple things and then
get on out of there he's not in those
things and everybody listening
people aren't and stuff peop your worth
is not in the certificates you're worth
not in the trophies you're worth nothing
little plaques
your worth is in the lives you changed
your worth is in the hearts you filled
up
your worth is
in your spiritual life and your worth is
innate
you have worth